our next guest lives the real fan life i
was at
mets cubs nlcs in october
i was in the upper deck and i run
into with a chicago cubs like
winter hat on sarah spain in the upper
deck
as a fan not with the media credential
like brockman
she's out there with a ticket because
she's a fan
freezing on the road at citi field
i said man we are kindred spirits i've
always loved listening to sarah spain
i'm not inviting her on the show today
just to talk about carmelo anthony we'll
get to that a little bit later
but i'm wondering i wanted to check in
on sarah to make sure she's doing okay
because all of her her cubs all the cubs
that won her her world
series are hitting home runs in other
teams how are you doing are you just
crying in wrigleyville with an old style
like how are you doing
ben thanks for having me and for
allowing me to have a little therapy
session here i
i described it last night i started with
just remove my eyeballs
uh that was my response to watching all
of them succeed in other places and i've
moved on to
this is like watching or looking at your
ex's wedding album on facebook um
like i'm i'm kind of happy for them
but also it it really sucks like
i've never had this before like by the
time jordan left for the wizards
um we kind of knew it was over and i was
off in college
i did drive from ithaca new york down to
dc to see jordan one last time in a
wizard juni
by myself in the nosebleeds in college
but um
i haven't had this where it's just like
take all of these people that you have
this incredible world
series moment with and say goodbye all
at once it hurts dude
but sports is a revolving door the only
constant sarah in life is change and as
you say goodbye to chris bryant
and rizzo and javi baez you get to
welcome lonzo
ball alex caruso and demar derozan to
chicago how great is that
honestly couldn't have come at a better
time and we're all getting those thanos
memes of like the bulls are back what
did it cost
the cubs uh yeah it was it was like
within very short order at least
something to put our attention on now i
don't anticipate we were going to get
a championship out of that crew but just
being relevant
just being people i want to watch play
basketball in a bold uniform
is something new because zach levine's
great obviously we got goose [ __ ] last
year but between covert and injuries we
never really got a chance to see what
those guys looked like together
in any real way um see add lonzo demar
deroza not only a great basketball
player but
such a good dude and i'm one of those
people that really likes cheering for
people that i like and having guys on my
team that i want to root for
so i'm pumped i mean it's been a while
this bulls hangover has been
since the jordan era in terms of you
know championships and then since
the d rose there i looked back it was
2015
when derek rose hit that bank shot three
and mean mugged the camera that was the
last time we got all
lathered up about the bulls in any real
way around here so it's been a while
sarah spain joins the show espn and
chicago red star's
co-owner you know i've got love for
chicago soccer
my late grandfather the legend frank
sarge crocker as united states soccer
hall of famer was the equipment manager
for the chicago sting they played out at
the rosemont horizon and then became the
chicago power
chicago is a soccer town in last dance
remember
that's right they're in the first act of
the last dance they used to sell yeah
they were telling us the bulls weren't
getting very many fans the chicago sting
we're outdrawing them
so chicago's got a rich soccer history
like i said i know it well
talk to me about your involvement with
the chicago red stars and where they fit
into the culture around the game out
there in chicago
well yet again as we mourn our cubs it's
been nice to have
the red stars to be winning a handful of
games of late and having some success
here at the top of
uh near the top of the standings um it's
been a big
learning curve uh ben i never
anticipated or even considered owning
a professional sports team i don't have
a monocle or a yacht
uh and as far as i know i don't have any
like uh
long lasting family oil money so it just
didn't seem like a possibility but
the angel city fc crew and abby womback
and and mia hamm and julie foughty and
glenn and doyle all those folks getting
together natalie portman
label on gory jennifer garner and and
putting together an expansion team
really opened up our eyes across the
league to a new ownership model and
i was so fortunate to have a
relationship with the majority owner of
the red stars
having thrown some tailgates there they
did a bobblehead day for me a couple
years ago because i've been a big fan
uh to be in the in the kind of universe
where they would think to reach out to
me and ask if it was
first financially feasible and second
something i'd be interested in
which was an immediate hell yeah like
it's a massive learning curve i kind of
paid a bunch of money to give myself
another job
is kind of what it feels like right now
but i love doing it and
um i think we're in for a massive bump
for the nwsl
in this year in the coming years so i'm
i'm ready to be
be a part of that and um 28th of this
month is when we get to welcome back our
four olympians that were
um four of the 18 were from my chicago
red stars team so
welcome them back as heroes and thank
them for representing us in tokyo and
being awesome
that's incredible i'm so excited to get
out to chicago and catch a game you know
how much love i have
for like i said the chicago soccer scene
it's in my family's blood and i think
it's so cool what you're doing with the
team to have four
olympians now coming back that's a big
deal not only for the organization but
for usa soccer
to have these stars continue to perform
and be seen
and visible and not just go you know
play in the world cup or the olympics
and kind of fall out of the zeitgeist
for a little bit
uh just team usa soccer talk to me a
little bit about your thoughts not only
on their performance
in tokyo but their cultural currency and
what they represent
in the american sports landscape yeah i
mean i think
not not grabbing gold hurts a ton and it
is
really difficult to be the team where if
you win it's like yeah of course
and if you lose it's a huge deal and
it's an embarrassment right i mean it's
it reminds me of serena williams just
talked about that in her peak years that
like no one really batted an eye when
she won
again but if she lost it was top of the
headlines that's a tough position to be
and that's a lot of pressure
so i'm bummed on their behalf that they
just couldn't put it together out there
to get gold
in tokyo but super proud of them anyway
and i don't think you could
underestimate their impact
on soccer in america not just women's
soccer
like a lot of people their entry their
their
gateway drug to premier league or mls or
nwsl
or you know any soccer in in
as an american has been the dominance of
that women's team
back to the 99ers you know brandy
chastain ripping her shirt off audi and
ham and all those
those early early heroes of ours and
then in more recent years
you know what then i call them instead
of just aspirational
i call them instructional i really do
feel like we're all watching them not
only be the very
best in the world at what they do but
then teach us
how to fight for equal pay teach us how
to be confident
and and like have that swagger as female
athletes that so often were sort of
denied or told to be either ladylike or
humble
i don't want that i want megan rupino on
a bus screaming i deserve this
right i want them to be showing us how
to do that because it's been far too
long where we haven't allowed
female athletes to have that kind of
swag so um yeah i mean i'm i'm
i'm a die-hard obsessive of the us
women's national team
so i'm looking forward to i'm planning
on going to the world cup new zealand
australia are you in
my whole family was talking about this
last week my aunt gene my aunt laura
they're gonna be in charge of getting
all the tickets
i went to australia for a mileage run
for two you know
for for god's sake so of course i gotta
go for the the women's world cup that is
definitely happening for the lions
family for sure
um sarah spain joins the show chicago
red star's co-owner you know
of course from espn sarah when would you
like to see justin field to play
quarterback for the bears
when he and the team are ready i'm not
one of those people
that needs to see him day one to prove
some sort of point
especially if the offensive line doesn't
feel
ready to protect him and and support him
especially if
he doesn't have a good enough grasp of
the office i think we've just seen some
some bad situations of guys picking up
habits getting happy feet
seeing ghosts they don't really feel
comfortable and then they have to kick
those
and they get away from what made them
great what made them get drafted high
and you know
we have this conversation all the time
in the nfl right what is it better
to let him sit behind someone and learn
or to get started right away and there
are examples of both
right you could absolutely throw out the
aaron rodgers
and the patma homes of the world and
then you can look at guys that got
thrust into good situations
that's the key they aren't just good
players but good situation so
if what you're seeing out of practice
and we're hearing a lot of good things
we're hearing a lot about him learning
really fast his his football intellect
um but if what you're seeing doesn't
feel right especially against the rams
week one go ahead and put andy dalton
out there that's that you got him
and you could use him and i would rather
see that than try to prove some point
with justin fields
if if he's not ready i really and i'm
optimistic about the guys they grabbed
for the offensive line
and added those pieces but i need to see
it in practice too
there was rumblings down in chicago the
bears might be moving they might be
moving from soldier field
truth to that so at first i completely
scoffed at it because this is a this is
a ploy we saw the cubs try to pull
a couple years ago that they were going
to go to rosemont and i'm like
listen let's just say you're about to
sell off your entire team
you're going to want to hang on to
wrigley field which is the place that
gets
thousands of people to show up no matter
how crap the team is
so we knew that that was a total bs you
know kind of
posturing to get the city to give them
more concessions that they wanted
i thought that was all that was
happening with the bears and i still
think that's the majority of it
this is coming at a time when they have
contracts up and they're trying to get
mayor laurie lightfoot in the rest of
the city to give them more concessions
on things that they want to build and
add
but it is worth pointing out that
soldier field doesn't necessarily have
the cachet of wrigley field it's not the
draw
the team is and there's tons of acreage
in the burbs that they could build
alongside a betting facility and all
this other stuff
so it's a possibility i still think
soldier field on the lakefront in
chicago itself as opposed to having one
of those
you know burbs that takes the name of
the city but isn't actually in it
i still think that's what they want um
but uh it's not quite as ridiculous
as the rosemont cubs wow that's that's
interesting i i heard it and i was like
that's absurd but you say there might be
some meat on the bone there
the chicago bears might play outside of
soldier field it's crazy because the
idea of
watching the bears play against the
packers and not being on
the lake freezing as you have a chi a
cheese grater on your head it just
doesn't feel like it's in chicago
first of all you should never have uh
you should never have a cheese grater on
your head even
even if you hate the cheese heads you
still just never wear a grater
you're better than that um but yeah no
there's just
it's first of all it was a protected
landmark so there was all that trouble
with that then they made some additions
and that took away that status but it's
still right there on that museum campus
there's
there's nowhere to build really there
there's such a limited amount of space
because it is right on the water and
near all those other things so that
would be the only reason but
again i'm going odds are we're sticking
at soldier field
espn sarah spain joins the show ben
line's phone in for rich on the rich
eisen show
sarah also a co-owner of the chicago red
stars
what was your favorite set at lala were
you out there in the pit for tyler
no i uh i decided to avoid being a part
of that
um i if the lineup is ever just like
killing it i'll be back i'm not
i'm not too old for lala in general but
it's got to be worth it and the last
couple years i found myself like
this is so embarrassing i'm not even a
mom but like i would see
some kid at 2pm and they're alone just
staring at a fence wall
like they're very clearly did a few too
many of whatever drug
they have no friends they have no phone
and instead of like enjoying myself and
being like what a loser haha
i'm like can i help you find your like
i'm just taking care of people instead
of watching
shows so like i might have aged out of
that part i did go to um
i went to band of horses after show and
mount joy after show and
i just discovered mount joy last year
during pandemic
and i've become obsessed they're one of
my new favorite bands so they absolutely
crushed and banded forces is always
legendary so
um i still got i still got my music in
but i stayed away from the
hundreds and thousands of people without
masks puking on themselves and not
knowing their own names for now
it's thursday it's okay to take the
bracelets off from the weekend it's okay
now you can cut them off
um you know the world changed the other
day it shifted we are now living in a
different universe
where were you when you found out that
carmelo was gonna have a chance to win a
title
yeah i just gotten over the fact that he
wasn't gonna be uh
flown out emergency style to tokyo to
save team usa like that was the last
real rumblings about mello that i'd
heard was captain america was needed but
uh
uh you know honestly ben i know you say
that because you think that i'm
anti-mello
i am not anti-mello you and i just have
differing opinions about the choices
he's made us throughout his career
and whether you know there's there
should be empathy for the fact that he's
never really
made any playoff noise or if that's a
result of the choices that he made
i think it'd be nice if he found his way
onto this team and got to have a good
deep run and be a part of it
and i think there's a really cool aspect
to the story of him and lebron coming
out of the same
uh draft class and and being friends and
working their way
to this point of playing alongside each
other um
but that's that's that's very big of me
to say because i don't know that i need
to root for the lakers to get another
type
let's just spread the love around a
little bit huh should i get a purple
jersey or a gold one what do you think
i'm gonna go purple is better with your
coloring by the way i've got to send you
a red star jersey you've got to be
rocking that
up in chicago soccer out in l.a down and
we got to do some type of
chicago sting collaboration or something
tap into the history of chicago soccer
throwback day where we're wearing
chicago's thing yeah oh
just some type of just yes it's all
about the little x
right that's what that's what culture is
in 2021 it's about the collaboration the
little
x i appreciate you collaborating on our
show and making it better
thank you sarah thanks for having me bud
i always love chatting with you go red
stars sarah spain
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here